der krieg schafft fronten auch in
deutschland russischstämmige menschen
erleben ein unbekanntes maß an
anfeindungen werden bedroht und
drangsaliert nach einem tag als diese
anrufe drohanrufe gekommen sind mussten
wir auch ehrlich gesagt die polizei
rufen in diesen zeiten trifft der zorn
leicht die falschen leider ist die
diese assoziationskette ganz kurz man
denkt russisch ist gleich russland ist
gleich putin aber das ist nicht so aber
es gibt auch fronten die ziehen sich
durch freundeskreise durch familien die
haben doch gesagt das ist also das was
ist da da ist kein krieg
[Musik]
christina enke ist geschäftsführerin im
russischen restaurant café dacia sie ist
in berlin geboren aber in kiew
aufgewachsen mit 20 kehrte sie zurück
nach deutschland
verwandtschaft und freunde sind noch in
kiew seit kriegsbeginn ist der umsatz
nicht nur in diesem restaurant um 30
prozent zurückgegangen die stimmung ist
angespannt
natürlich persönlich habe ich angst um
meine familie dort in der ukraine aber
hier in berlin geschäftlich
ich habe angst dass wenn es nicht zu
ende geht dass wir
dadurch dass wir als russisches just
wrong gesehen werden wirklich darunter
dann leiden auch auf langfristige zeit
die mitarbeiter aus dem kaffeebecher
kommen aus ganz europa aus moldau
lettland aus russland die belegschaft
hält zusammen doch in diesen
dramatischen tagen machen sie
verstörende erfahrungen sie bekommen
drohanrufe im internet finden sich
negative kommentare
ich rate ihnen den namen zu ändern bevor
etwas passiert
seit dem 24 2 das ist überhaupt nicht
mehr
dort sollte man nicht einkaufen geld
fische
könnt ihr bitte euren laden erstmals
schließen oder seid ihr putin treu wir
wollten als restaurant als gastronomin
nicht in den krieg mit hineingezogen
werden aber nach einem tag als diese
anrufe drohanrufe gekommen sind mussten
wir auch ehrlich gesagt die polizei
rufen
haben anzeige erstattet gegen diese
menschen die angerufen haben
nicht nur im café dacia gibt es solche
fälle seit der krieg in der ukraine
begonnen hat also die taten die haben
die relativ große spannbreite das reicht
von online boykottaufrufen gegen
restaurants die dann russisch sind oder
für russisch gehalten werden über
beleidigungen und drohungen dass es
etwas was wir nicht tolerieren sollten
wo menschen die im zweifelsfall seit
jahrzehnten hier leben für einen krieg
verantwortlich gemacht werden mit dem
sie erst mal nichts zu tun haben und das
ist etwas wogegen sich die gesellschaft
natürlich stellen sollte
putins krieg trifft auch mitten in das
leben russischsprachiger familien
alexandra und evgeny sind musiklehrer in
bremen
alexandra ist in der ukraine er ist in
russland geboren
die russin die ihr hier kennt sind gegen
diesen krieg
aber evgeny es verwandte in russland
design taub für argumente sagt alexandra
die glauben und alle diese ganze
propaganda da dort die glauben dass
die russen sind gekommen um mein volk zu
retten
hier glauben richtig dass und das ist
schrecklich
seit gut einer woche sind alexandras
eltern in sicherheit
aus kiew nach bremen geflüchtet und
voller verzweiflung und wut
putin hat gelogen lügt und wird auch
weiter lügen er ist einfach zu uns
gekommen und erzählt allen dass er
befreit aber wen er befreit das ist die
frage die
er tötet unsere kinder tötet unser volk
evgeny es eltern leben in russland eng
war ihr kontakt nie sie zu überzeugen
dass durch putins krieg tausende sterben
erscheint ihm aussichtslos auch seine
frau konnte die schwiegereltern in
russland nicht überzeugen ich persönlich
habe das gefühl dass versuch diese
informations blase zu
überqueren
führt zu einer sehr starken und sehr
aggressiven gegenreaktion die anders
gesagt das ganze also das was ist da da
ist kein krieg das ist kein krieg also
eure
das faschistische regierung hat das
alles verursacht
und wir sind schuld nein nein
alexandra hat jede verbindung zu ihren
schwiegereltern gelöscht also da brechen
soweit ich das beurteilen kann wirklich
beziehungen ab am küchentisch und online
die
ob sie die jeweils zu kippen sind wird
die zukunft zeigen aber das dürfte
schwierig werden im zweifelsfall weil
dieser krieg ist sehr sehr blutig es gab
diese konflikte in den familien schon
2014 nach der aktion der krim aber das
was wir jetzt haben ist natürlich viel
gewalttätiger hat ein ganz anderes
ausmaß das sind viel schwerere
verwerfungen ein riss geht auch durch
die russisch orthodoxe kirche
gottesdienst in ratingen bei düsseldorf
russen ukrainer deutsche beten hier
gemeinsam für den frieden in der ukraine
das ist nicht selbstverständlich in
diesen zeiten denn der
russisch-orthodoxe patriarch kyrill
steht dann putins seite rechtfertigt
seinen krieg als kampf gegen den
sündigen westen gegen die kräfte des
bösen
trotzdem veröffentlichten russische
geistliche einen mutigen appell zitat
kein gewaltloser aufruf zum frieden und
zur beendigung des krieges darf
gewaltsam zurückgewiesen und als verstoß
gegen das gesetz betrachtet werden
der dekan und der erzpriester aus
ratingen haben unterschrieben sie
gehören zu den knapp 300 geistlichen die
sich das trauten dabei sein so viel mehr
mit dem krieg nicht einverstanden
berichtet der erzpriester wird der humor
ich finde es sind viel zu wenig
unterschriften weil wir haben 40.000
priester die in russland leben und
gottesdienste ausführen aber die
priester und haben angst
der krieg erschüttert und spaltet auch
die gemeinde in ratingen es war sehr
schwer am anfang die emotionen in den
griff zu bekommen manche worte wurden
gesagt die menschen normalerweise nicht
sagen würden und viele dinge sind
passiert die menschen normalerweise
nicht zu und tut
sie versuchen wieder zusammenzufinden
sich mut zu machen einige der russischen
mitglieder haben die gemeinschaft
verlassen wir waren so gute freunde
so viel geholfen und jetzt plötzlich
durch diese verschiedene politische
standpunkte gehen wie er fast wie nicht
wir wollen das ändern so ein bisschen
auf zurückhaltende personen hier und das
will ich überhaupt nicht in unserer
gemeinde die spaltung ist überall ich
denke dass es in der ukraine allein drin
in russland rinal ein sehr großes
spaltung zwischen menschen
hier in deutschland auf jeden fall
natürlich
anastasia steht mit ihrer mutter im
täglichen kontakt sie kam mit ihrer
jüdischen familie als
kontingentflüchtlinge in den 90ern aus
moskau nach deutschland ein teil der
familie lebt noch in der ukraine seit
dem krieg ist auch für sie nichts mehr
wie es war
wir waren die ganze zeit
erstmal im schock und dann haben wir
angefangen humanitäre hilfe zu sammeln
und dann menschen zu helfen eine
unterkunft zu finden haben auch selber
geflüchtete aufgenommen im zuge der
sanktionen gegen russland wurden ihre
konten und auch die ihrer familie bei
der deutschen bank eingeschränkt sie
mussten bei der bank erst einen
dauerhaften wohnsitz in deutschland und
einen unbefristeten aufenthaltstitel
nachweisen anastasia hat einen
russischen und einen deutschen pass die
eltern haben russische pässe inzwischen
können sie die konten wieder
eingeschränkt nutzen doch ein
beklemmendes gefühl bleibt
als die konten gesperrt waren war eine
große ungewissheit und auch ein großes
gefühl von ungerechtigkeit wir sind ich
würde schon gern flüchtlinge und wir
leben hier seit 25 jahren
und es war ein gefühl das man sich jetzt
alles gemacht werden kann
anastasia überlebte den antisemitischen
anschlag auf die synagoge in halle doch
mit ihrem russisch klingenden namen habe
sie ebenfalls anfeindungen erfahren sie
spricht von antiislamischen rassismus
wohnungen seien ihr nicht vermietet
worden manche verträge habe sie nicht
abschließen können den aktuellen zorn
durch putins krieg angefacht hält sie
für bedrohlich ich erlebe antisemitismus
weil ich jude bin und aber auf den
alltäglichen basis erlebe ich viel mehr
antiislamischen rassismus deswegen weiß
ich dass es da ist zu 80 wenn so gar
nicht zu 90 prozent sind alle jüdischen
gemeinden in deutschland russisch sprach
ich komplett ist sind viele die aus der
ukraine stammen ist sind viele die aus
russland stammen ist ging und anderen
ehemaligen sowjet starten
diese menschen erleben
doppelten doppelte ausgrenzung sowohl
aufgrund der russisch sprach ich kein
als auch aufgrund von der jüdischen
zugehörigkeit der krieg in der ukraine
könnte hierzulande alte vorurteile
verstärken
experten wie professor petersen sehen
darin durchaus eine gefahr das ist nur
abschätzigen blick gibt auch vieles in
osteuropa das hat eine lange tradition
und da gibt es sicher dinge die jetzt
angeknüpft wird oder es ist relativ
schnell wieder da
maxi schewski ist in sankt petersburg
geboren kam 1990 nach deutschland
sie ist journalistin bei radio gallus
berliner einem sender für die
russischsprachige bevölkerung in der
hauptstadt
über putins angriffskrieg sind
krzyzewski und ihre kollegen entsetzt
sie sorgt sich aber auch über eine
zunehmende russen feindlichkeit
diese assoziationskette ganz kurz man
denkt russisch ist gleich russland ist
gleich putin aber das ist nicht so weil
uns springen jetzt zum beispiel
werbekunden ab und ein ganz großer kunde
zum beispiel jetzt den wir seit zehn
jahren hatten
wollten plötzlich nichts mehr mit ihm zu
tun haben der kleine radiosender
registriert all die anfeindungen über
die berichtet wird drohanrufe in
russischen bars und restaurants zuletzt
traf es die internationale lomonossow
schule in berlin marzahn dort verübten
unbekannte einen brandanschlag über die
ereignisse zu berichten ist futter auch
für putins propaganda sie zu
verschweigen allerdings keine
alternative wenn wir es nicht benennen
würden würden wir genau so putin in die
hände spielen wie werden wir das neue
tief und immer einfach übernehmen
sondern was wir machen müssen ist es
korrekt zu benennen weil es gibt
nachweisbar eine instrumentalisierung
dieser vorfälle einmal durch kreise die
der aus der community die der arena
stehen und dann durch die russische
regierung und auch durch die russische
botschaft ganz konkret hier in
deutschland für solche propaganda im
sinne putins wird mit fake news
gearbeitet jüngstes beispiel in den
sozialen medien kursierte ein video in
dem eine frau unter tränen aus sagt in
euskirchen sei ein russe von ukrainern
ermordet worden die geschichte ist
komplett erfunden das bestätigt auch die
polizei das hatten wir 2016 schon damals
der sogenannte fall lisa das war damals
auch nicht richtig und ist es auch immer
noch nicht und diskutieren halte
whatsapp gruppen und auf den social
media plattform viele videos bei denen
völlig unklar ist wo sie herkommen der
fall lisa 2016 nach der annexion der
krim das mädchen mit deutsch russischen
eltern sei von migranten vergewaltigt
worden hieß es in den russischen medien
daran stimmt nichts
die gezielten falschmeldungen sollten
während der flüchtlingskrise die
stimmung in deutsch russischen kreisen
anheizen
die journalistin maria klubchef ski weiß
dass jeder bericht über anfeindungen in
deutschland putins propaganda in die
hände spielt doch den real existierenden
bedrohungen jetzt etwas entgegenzusetzen
das ist dir sehr wichtig das geht mir
sehr viel kraft die menschen aufzuklären
und die menschen zu erzählen das werden
sie alles was russisch klingt oder
russisch richter oder russisch schmeckt
wenn sie das alles verjagen werden sie
damit ukraine nicht helfen im gegenteil
sie geben damit und das muss man ganz
klar deutlich sagen sie geben damit
futter den kreml propaganda medien in
russland weil das ist natürlich ganz
toll jetzt dort zu berichten wie rahmen
russen werden jetzt sogar in europa
unterdrückt und verfolgt und das darf
nicht sein
manchmal stößt auch mancher kritik an
ihre grenzen ein enger schulfreund aus
russland steht weiter zu putin er ist
nicht der einzige und da sind menschen
die auch die welt gesehen haben und das
ist schrecklich und deswegen gehören
diese menschen für mich jetzt so leid es
mir tut der vergangenheit und ich nenne
das jetzt mein virtuellen friedhof und
da liegen jetzt alle meine freunde
begraben wir denken dass die ukraine im
moment and i ffi ziert wird
wie der radiojournalistin ergeht es
jetzt vielen der krieg trend menschen
die gestern noch freunde waren oder
familie und ein ende ist nicht in sicht
[Musik]